(loud whoosh)
(click)
(beeping)
(cheerful piano music)
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape,
bipedal, naked, large-brained,
lone the master of fire,
tools and language,
but still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable,
yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future
from our shared understanding of the past.
CARTA brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who
we are and how we got here,
an exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
(techno music)
(synthesizer music)
- So, some of you know my
interest in anthropology,
and it originated from
studies in sialic acid,
biology changes, and human evolution.
And my background as a physician
led me to explore human-specific diseases.
So, what then am I doing here
talking about death
awareness and mortality?
In 2005, I lectured at
the University of Arizona
and ventured beyond my expertise
opining about the evolution
of human cognition.
At the lunch that followed,
a local professor sat next to me and said,
"You are all asking the wrong question!"
Danny Brower's point was
perhaps we should not be
asking how human minds evolved.
There have been
highly intelligent,
warm-blooded, social creatures
around for tens of thousands of years,
elephants, Corvid birds,
apes, and dolphins.
So, why are we not having to compete
with these other species?
Danny suggested that it was not just that
something unusual happened
during human evolution,
but also that all these other species
were blocked in progression
by a cognitive barrier
that only we had broken through.
So, I was really intrigued
by this contrarian view,
and we talked a long time
after everyone was gone,
and I strongly recommended
that he publish.
Seeing nothing in print
after more than a year,
I followed up with emails.
Got no responses.
Looked up his phone number on the Internet
only to find his obituary.
Danny had died very suddenly
of an unusual disease
called aortic dissection.
I contacted his friend
Sean Carroll who said
Danny had indeed been
working on some novel idea
but never published.
After more than two decades
of exploring anthropogeny,
I could see some real important
potential in Danny's idea
and I just could not let it die with him.
Fortunately, the editor of
Nature, Phillip Campbell,
allowed me to write a
letter about Danny's idea
with some embellishments.
I thought I had done my duty
and could leave it to
experts to follow up.
But, a week later, I got an email
from Danny Brower's widow, Sharon,
thanking me for writing the letter.
Told me that Danny had started a book
and asked if I would like to read it.
Looking at his draft, I
realized that his thinking
had progressed very much
in the way mine had,
and we'd come to very similar
conclusions independently.
But, there were great challenges
in completing this book.
First, one author was dead,
(audience laughs)
and the other wanted to preserve
the original intent and prose.
Second, I really had no time
to do full justice to it
because of my lack of expertise,
and also lack of time.
And last, but not least,
who would care about a book
by a dead insect geneticist and
a living physician scientist
who claimed to have
explained the human mind?
(audience laughing)
So, I sat on this for a while,
but fortunately a friend of mine,
Abraham Verghese, an author,
put me in touch with
his agent, Mary Evans,
who saw the potential in the book
and called Miss Cary
Goldstein at Twelve Books
to help me with it.
And so, I went on.
Strike four, which I won't talk
about, is Superstorm Sandy.
Strike five was poor
follow through on my part
because of lack of
expertise and lack of time.
(audience laughs)
And last but not least
was a book title that the
publisher insisted on,
which was Denial.
(audience laughing)
So, for a while I thought that this was
a hackneyed old phrase
that had so many meanings
that it didn't really
say what I wanted to say.
And, in fact, if you looked in Amazon,
you would find not only
the famous important book
related to this topic Denial of Death,
but numerous books with
the word denial in them.
(audience laughing)
The more I thought about it, I realized
that actually the publisher
and agent were right.
All these books are talking really
about various versions
of the same phenomenon,
the human penchant for denying reality.
And, in fact, as you read more,
I found other books by
many famous authors,
all of which are on different topics,
but all contain pieces of the same story,
our human ability to ignore reality.
Let me give you some practical examples.
As a physician, I'm
acutely aware of the fact
that lack of exercise, unhealthy diet,
tobacco use, ignoring
obesity, high blood pressure,
sleep apnea, poor hygiene,
and excessive red meat
are bad for you, but I'm not going to ask
for a show of hands because,
(audience laughing)
physicians like myself are equally guilty.
Then we have massive denial
of scientific reality,
biological evolution, climate change,
magical cures, vaccines don't work,
worse still, they cause autism
despite it being debunked,
UFOs, of course, weird cancer
risks, not the real ones.
And here in San Diego,
fluoride in the water is a communist plot.
(audience laughing)
And then there are many
examples of societal denial
of practical reality, national debt.
Each of you owes $150,000.
Healthcare costs, end of life costs,
covert racism, population growth,
and insistence on rebuilding
in exactly the places
where the worst of earthquakes, floods,
and hurricanes have occurred.
(audience laughs)
And then, of course, the examples
of political distortion of reality.
(audience laughing)
I'm not going to read this slide.
You know what I'm talking about.
(audience laughing)
But to be fair, there
are plenty of examples
of distortion of reality at the other end
of the political spectrum.
I think Calvin puts it well to Hobbes.
"It's not denial.
"I'm just very selective about
the reality that I accept."
(audience laughing)
So, after writing the
book, I had much difficulty
finding a single word or phrase
that encompasses phenomenons.
I'm going to a phrase I
didn't find in the dictionary,
reality denial, as I'm defining as
some kind of subconscious
defense mechanism
characterized by refusal to acknowledge
or rationalization of
unwanted or unpleasant facts,
realities, thoughts or feelings.
Now, so I think we have
to add reality denial
to the long list of
unusual and exaggerated
cognitive features of humans,
some of which are listed here.
But, for most of these other features,
we can think of good reasons
why they might have evolved
in terms of benefiting humans.
But the reality denial, there's a mystery.
Excessive reality denial of
the kind that humans practice
should be an evolutionary maladaptation.
Excessive reality denial
should result in excessive risk taking
and the individuals who have
the genetic ability to
do that should disappear.
(audience laughing)
So, how and why did
excessive reality denial
and risk taking evolve in humans?
And what benefits outweighed
those negative consequences?
So, this brings me another
extension of Danny's idea
that the independent
evolution of self-awareness
in the very same intelligent creatures
that we've discussed before,
although, there are lots of arguments
about the techniques used
and the real conclusions,
it's reasonably clear that chimpanzees
and perhaps elephants,
dolphins and magpies
can recognize themselves in the mirror
and have some kind of sense of self.
It's hard to define exactly what it is,
but they certainly do have this.
So, are animals and birds with
awareness of their own self
also aware of the self-awareness
of others of their own kind?
I asked myself that question
and did some reading
and realized I was
thinking about something
that's been well-studied
called Theory of Mind.
The ability to attribute mental beliefs,
desires, intentions and perspectives
to oneself and to others
and to understand that others also have
beliefs, desires,
intentions, and perspectives
that are similar or
different from one's own.
There are many other related terms,
intentionality, et cetera,
that I won't go through,
but they're all overlapping terms.
But after reading further, I realized
there's a continuum in
the cognitive development
of Theory of Mind and Intentionality.
A two-year-old human
passes the mirror test.
A three to four-year-old human has
a more rudimentary theory
of mind that emerges.
A five-year-old human
has a full theory of mind
and can tell excellent lies.
(audience laughing)
But, adult humans have something
that I might call extended theory of mind
or multi-order intentionality,
the ability to do what
we're doing right now.
You're reading my mind,
I'm reading your mind,
and there are 100 people
or several hundred people
across the world on the live Internet
watching and thinking what you're thinking
or perhaps something different.
And with the Internet,
of course, we can have
millions of minds melted across
the world at the same time.
So, the question, and this
is of course a continuum,
the question arises, why is
this extended theory of mind
so well-developed in adult humans
and apparently not in other species?
So here's my expansion of Danny's idea.
I suggest that it was a
psychological evolutionary barrier
that held back all these
other intelligent species
at about this point in the
evolution of theory of mind.
What might that barrier be?
We can now come back to
the theme of this symposium
and suggest there's also a continuum
in awareness of death risk
and understanding a person's mortality.
I may not have my numbers exactly correct,
but it seems to me that you first have
an automated reaction to death risk,
which, as Joe pointed out,
many species, or all species should have
some kind of awareness of death risk.
And if some kind of self-awareness
is enhanced at that time,
you'd maybe become aware of the
death of another individual.
But, if I substitute
crows for magpies here,
it's the very same
animal, birds and birds,
that seem to have evolved some
of kind of awareness of death
you heard about earlier in the symposium
that seems right on the
cusp of what humans have,
and yet, just short of it.
So the operative word here
is mortality salience,
conscious understanding and realization
of one's personal mortality.
So, if you go down this continuum,
well, death anxiety may require
extended theory of mind.
Truly understanding the
death of another individual
would result in
understanding the mortality
of other individuals.
And this conscious
awareness would exaggerate
the systems we've heard about
that extends to not just actual events,
but even thinking about it
at the level of
consciousness, as Joe said.
Such individuals would then have
a reduction in reproductive fitness.
Evolution doesn't care if you survive.
Evolution cares if you reproduce,
and I suspect that those individuals
who first ran into this barrier,
and maybe it happened many
times in many species,
had a reduction in reproductive fitness
and could not transmit their genotype.
So then the emergence of
extended theory of mind
would result in awareness of mortality
and, again, a failure to fix
the genotype into species.
We've already said that reality
denial should be negative,
so what if these two unusual
cognitive features emerged
in the same minds at the same time,
the rare double negative,
which would could result
sufficient tolerance of death anxiety
to establish the combination in a species.
Thus, perhaps, two rare
evolutionary maladaptations or
negatives could've coincided
to allow this mind over
reality transition.
I have a much more extended view of this
that we don't have time to discuss.
(audience laughs)
I need to talk to them experts, too,
before I go any further with that.
But any theory that makes progress
is bound to be initially counterintuitive.
So I'd like to suggest that
this hypothetical singular
phase in human evolution
in which mortality salience
and maladaptive death anxiety
were triggered by acquiring
extended theory of mind,
which resulted in understanding
personal mortality,
but then when one time only was stabilized
by simultaneous acquisition
of general reality denial
in the same minds.
I remember asking Danny.
There couldn't be a death denial module.
Well, he came to the
same conclusion I have.
We just deny anything we don't like.
(audience laughs)
So there are other consequences,
afterlife myths,
superstitions, religiosity,
self deception, over
confidence, risk taking,
and last but not least, the optimism bias.
Humans are well known to
be irrationally optimistic.
Many studies have shown
this, even fMRI studies.
And evolutionary modeling
(audience laughs)
shows that reacting in
an over confident manner
can have fitness benefits,
as long as the contested
resource is sufficiently large
compared to the cost of competition.
Now, if you combine over confidence
with extended theory of
mind, you've got big success.
(audience laughs)
Of course, here is a case, I believe,
of initially successful
but eventually fatal case
of reality denial.
So, how important is reality denial?
Let's do a thought
experiment and delete it.
Well, some other features of humans
would get dimmed or partially eliminated.
But let's now dim theory
of mind and eliminate that,
and you'd find that most of these
unusual exaggerated
cognitive features of humans,
while they could still be
present, would be greatly dimmed,
so I suggest that this combination
could give you this transition,
which is consistent so
far with all known facts,
compatible with other theories,
not negated by currently known facts,
but is not directly testable
by experimental reproduction
or directly falsifiable by
experimental approaches.
Now, the great tragedy of science
is the slaying of a beautiful
hypothesis by an ugly fact.
(audience laughs)
And I've been searching for that fact
to destroy this hypothesis.
If you can find it, let me know.
But it can't just be, "I don't like it."
(audience laughs)
So when did this occur in
human evolution, finally?
We know that about two million years ago,
our ancestors from
Africa, some stayed behind
and some spread all across the Old World
to give rise to Neanderthals
and many other species.
This went on for almost two million years,
leaving behind many
species and subspecies.
But the types of things
that you might think
might be related to theory of
mind, reality denial leaves
no signal in the record I can think of.
But symbolic art, complex tool making,
personal ornamentation,
burials with added materials,
all occur around 100 to
200 thousand years ago.
Again, the experts will be
much more precise than I am.
This happens to be about the
time that the human migration
and the peopling of the world occurred
in which our species evolved in Africa
and gradually spread across the world
and essentially took over the planet.
And we are now,
unlike most of the subspecies
or the multiple species,
we are the lone survivors and
the masters of the planet.
So, while we can't be sure,
I'd like to speculate that
the evolution of
anatomically modern humans
into behaviorally modern humans,
which is seen in the archeological record,
although that's quite incomplete,
may have at least partly
involved this transition.
So, it so happens this theory
can provide a unifying explanation
for several unusual
exaggerated features of humans,
such as theory of mind, which
is beneficial for many things,
reality denial, strong
tendency for self deception
and false beliefs,
overarching optimism bias,
risk taking behavior,
recent emergence, perhaps,
as a dominant species, and
replacement of everybody else.
Remember, this would have
to have a genetic basis.
There are some examples
of supporting evidence
I don't have time to talk about,
and issues arising in future directions
I don't have time to talk about, but
(audience laughs)
I would point out that
some of the brain regions
in modern optimism
bias, anxiety, and so on
are related to some of these things.
So finally, let me close by
coming back to Danny Brower.
From Danny Brower's 2007 draft manuscript.
"We are polluting the Earth
and changing the climate
"in ways that we can't predict
"and likely at some point
can't easily reverse.
"If we're so smart, why do we continue
"to sow the seeds for
our eventual destruction?
"Perhaps because we are
saddled with a brain
"that is designed by selection
"to cope with the
ultimate disaster, death,
"by denying it will occur,
"and so we treat all
the impending disasters
"by denying they will ever happen.
"Indeed, it is arguable that
"we are destined to destroy
ourself as a species."
2007.
You don't have to listen
to climate scientists.
Just look at the HSBC bank's projection
for what they're gonna run into
in terms of extreme weather events.
Personally, I think this is the case
where legitimate fear
mongering is appropriate.
(audience laughs)
It's global and local climate disruption,
not just climate change, affecting you
and everybody else that
you know in your backyard.
Again, this quote I found
in Danny's manuscript,
"A man who carries a cat by the tail
"learns something he can
never learn in any other way."
(audience laughs)
We have caught the
climate tiger by the tail,
and we better let go soon.
Finally, from Danny's manuscript,
he had a lot of cartoons I
couldn't reproduce in the book
for copyright reasons,
but I'm just showing one of them.
Doctor to Earth.
"The bad news is you've
got advanced stage humans.
"The good news is they've
just about run their course
"and you should be on the mend soon."
(audience laughs)
So with that, I'd like to
close with the idea that
two rare evolutionary maladaptations,
this is just a theory for discussion,
might have coincided to allow
the mind over reality transition.
Thank you.
(audience applauds)
(techno music)